Okay.
Good morning.
Over the weekend you were
assigned material from
chapter one of the text and it
dealt really with three famous
beginnings of pieces of classical music.
Somebody tell me at the outset,
what were those three famous pieces?
Young lady down here.
Okay.
Beethoven's Fifth Symphony.
What was the second one?
Uh,
yeah, I a piano concerto number one
of Tchaikovsky and the third one?
Yeah. This piece by Ricard Strauss
with this funny sounding German name,
we'll just call it Zuora through
struck this profit Zahra through steps.
Those were the three pieces and the
issues there had to do with musical genre
that we're going to talk a little
bit more about in a moment and the
instruments,
the instruments,
and you went ahead and worked
with listening exercises
nine through 11 to engage
the musical instruments, um, a
bit in those particular exercises.
And we have performers here today
that are going to, as you can see,
a demonstrate some of these
instruments instruments for us.
Let's make one point
very clear at the outset.
Oftentimes I get student papers that
refer to Beethoven's fifth song or
Tchaikovsky's First Piano Song.
Is that right? Now that's not,
that's not good at all. Uh,
are these songs well, what,
what do you have to have
to make something, a song,
lyrics.
You got to have a text.
So we don't have in
80% of classical music.
We don't have lyrics. We don't have a
tech. Well, yes with opera of course,
but the other 80% is
purely instrumental music.
It works its magic again,
through purely instrumental means.
So we can't really call those songs.
And this puzzle me,
one day I was sitting there at iTunes
and I wanted to buy an interior movement
of a Mozart serenade.
Ah,
so I was all set to purchase
this and it said by song,
boom,
that told me the answer.
That's where this terminology comes into
play because on iTunes we buy songs.
It could be purely instrumental,
but it's called by a soul.
But we don't want to use that sort
of parlance. We want to be more,
a bit more sophisticated than that,
if you will, and use other terms.
So we'll we'll talk generally
about Beethoven's composition
or Beethoven's piece
or Beethoven's work or his
masterwork or chef do for raw,
however fancy you want to get with it.
We could also go on and be a little
more precise and say it belongs to a
particular genre.
We could use the name of the genre,
and I'll be talking a lot about the genre
in this course is your aura is simply
a fancy word for type or so what
genre of peace is this by Beethoven?
Well, it's a symphony.
Symphonies. Have four movements,
have four movements.
What's a movement? Well,
a movement is simply an
independent piece that works.
Oftentimes if they're multiple movements
in the symphony or concerto worked with
other movements, they are independent,
yet they are complimentary.
Think of,
for example,
a sculpture garden you might have
for independent sculptures in there,
but they relate one to another.
They make some sort of
special since one to another.
So symphonies have these four movements
and they usually operate in the
following way, a fast
opening movement, a slower,
more lyrical second movement.
Then a third movement that's derived from
the dance. And then a fourth movement,
fourth movement. That's sort of, again,
uptempo, fast in phatic conclusion.
Uh,
let's see how these play out.
Let's see how these play out by means
of a quick review of Beethoven's Fifth
Symphony. So all we're
going to do here, Linda,
is going to go from the beginning
of the track for the first movement,
the second movement and so on. And
uh, well let's just start here.
Let's just by way of,
of refreshing our memory,
the beginning of
Beethoven's fifth symphony.
Okay,
pause it there. And as we
said last time, it operates
in that fashion and that beginning
gives us a good opportunity to make a
distinction between two types of melody,
between this idea of a motive and a theme.
Both are sort of subsets of
melody. If you, uh, if you will,
uh,
as I say in the textbook there,
the beginning of the Beethoven fifth is
something like a musical punch in the
nose, right? Bought out at,
I'm sort of grabbing you
here, hitting you in the face,
whatever. Musically, it's
not a very long idea.
How many notes is in this opening
gambit here? How many pictures for Bop,
bop, Bop, bop, short, short,
short, long. Okay, so that's
a classic example of a motive.
A motive is just a little salad Europe,
out of which the composure,
we'll build other musical material.
Now let's contrast that with what happens
in the second movement of Beethoven's
Fifth Symphony where we
have a lyrical long flowing
theme.
Okay?
Okay, we'll stop there. All right, so
that went on. If we heard the whole thing,
it actually goes on for 32
notes as opposed to just for,
so motive versus longer themes,
themes,
10 maybe a little bit more lyrical.
Now let's go onto the third movement.
We said the third movement was danced
derived, but in this case with Beethoven,
it's a very strange dance.
If it is dance derive,
it's just a little bit different
than most of these third movements,
but less listen to it anyway, because I'd
like you to, when the brass is, come in,
think about what you're hearing and think
about that. Visa VI the first movement.
So let's hear the third movement now.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
okay, so what happened there
when the brasses came in?
How did that relate to the first movement?
Yes.
For notes, something as simple
as that, that the t, t, t,
t, t, t, same rhythmic ideas.
So that's usually the motive there and
that's how these movements are tied
together a little bit.
Let's go on to the finale now.
And as we listened to the finale,
let's think about what we heard at the
very beginning and talked about last time
that the mood that the beginning of
the fifth symphony created for it.
We had these adjectives up, your
negative, anxious, unsettled.
Well how do we feel now
about the finale and why
[inaudible]
you just turn the volume down
a little bit as we go down. Uh,
so why do we feel differently about that?
I think we do. What do we feel there?
Well, sort of upbeat, positive,
what's turned all of this around?
What specifically? Well with the first
movement, we said he's generally going
that kind of idea,
but now it's,
and we'll explore this when we get to
harmony, this idea of major and minors,
that's
a,
from the dark
minor to the brighter major.
We were going down in the first movement.
Now we will,
it's going up and instead of
having just the violins playing,
we have the trumpets,
the heroic trumpets.
So it sounds very triumphant,
very triumphant.
So in this 40 minute interval we've gone
sort of through an emotional musical
journey here from despair,
despondency,
uncertainty to whatever to personal trial
and in a way that mirrors some of the
things that were going on
in Beethoven's life. Okay.
Let's go on to talk
about the second piece.
We're finished with this idea of
the genre of the four movement.
The symphony go on to talk about the
piano concerto concertos are generally in
three movements.
So the concerto is another genre.
It's a genre in which a soloist will
confront the orchestra and there'll be a
kind of give and take,
a spirited give and take between the two.
So now we are going to listen to it.
The beginning of the first movement
of Jakafi Skis, a piano concerto.
You've worked with this already,
so you're a little bit familiar with it.
And at the outset here,
I have two questions for you.
Is the beginning here played,
uh,
played by the brasses are the strings,
in other words,
what are the woodwinds,
what family of instruments is playing
here and his Tchaikovsky using a motive?
Or is he using a theme at the
very beginning of this concerto?
Okay,
Linda,
just off a little bit.
[inaudible]
yeah, please. Let's do that again so we
can hear the, you're at the beginning.
So what about that theme or motive
at the beginning? Moda. All right,
so here it was, I think, how
many notes in our motive?
Same as in the Beethoven. What,
why isn't it the say? Well,
we got a skippy Beethoven, uh, here,
which a Kowski is coming
down just straight down,
down a consecutive intervals
there for the most part.
And both of them are however minor
with the checkoff ski. They,
all the, the intervals of the,
the durations of the same. The Bop,
Bop beep up, up, up, up with the,
with the Beethoven tee, tee,
tee, tee, short, short, short,
long. So Schakowsky is keys.
Uh, a little bit more neutral
in terms of the rhythm. Okay.
So then we go on and the piano
enters. Oh, what is the panel doing?
So let's hear the piano come in
just a bit. Just play bit. Yeah.
More.
Okay, let's stop here. So
what's the piano up to? Well,
the piano is Jeff playing chords,
playing them in octave.
Six sessions.
And we'll talk about that
a little bit more too.
So why don't we have here
in this next section?
Do we have a theme or do we have a motive?
And which are the violins
play? Are they, uh,
do they have the theme or the motive
or does the piano have the theme or the
motive?
Let's listen.
Okay. So let's, let's stop it
there. Uh, so was what the,
what were the violins play theme or
motive? See, what was the piano doing?
Yeah,
just the same course.
Yadidi Bop,
bop, bop, bop,
bop, bop, bop, bop,
fashion.
I'm singing the melody.
They're playing a chordal
accompaniment against it. All right,
let's listen to the next
iteration of this team.
We've identified this as a theme.
Who's got the theme now?
Is it exactly the same and what are
the strings up to in terms of string
technique here?
Just pause it.
Sit
there. So, uh, who had
the theme cattle now,
but was it exactly the same?
Not really.
It's kind of noodling around
with a varying, a little bit.
What were the strings doing?
They were playing the accompaniment and
what string technique where they use it.
I think we mentioned that in the
first chapter of the book there. Yep.
You've got it nice and loud
please. Pitsa Kata. Good. Okay.
Pizzicato we could write that. We
write that as a term of, yeah. Okay.
We've got it up there. PITSA
Cup. That's a help. Um, so the,
in that particular case, we've
switched the roles around. Let's,
um,
let's go ahead and do two to 10.
We're going to move this along
just a little bit here. Uh,
as we come back into this,
I think we've got a situation where the,
the piano keeps playing the four note
modals and keep building it up for tension
and there's a cascade and then the theme
comes back. Let's see what happens here.
Just the motive. One,
two, three, four. Okay.
Okay.
All right. So that's an
introduction to a three movement.
Piano Concerto happens to be the first
of the three movements and it's pretty
spectacular music. I hope you
liked that music. It's one of the,
one of the great melodies of all time.
It's a, it's a wonderful example of the,
of a theme.
Having talked just a
little bit about genres,
we could conclude by saying there are
other kinds of genres in music. Of course,
we're a, we've been introduced
to this idea of the tone poem.
The Strauss Zahra through Straw is a
tone poem that's a kind of one movement
work in which the composure tries to
tell a story or play out in an historic
event or in the case of the Strauss,
I guess to give us the beginning of
the contents of a philosophical novel
through music.
So tone poems or one movement.
And we have got other kinds of
genres and music. We've got opera,
we've got cantatas, Sonatas,
ballets, things such as this.
And we'll get to each of those in turn.
So that's the end of
the discussion of genre.
Let's go on now to talk about instruments
and how instruments produce sound.
Eva Heater. Come on up. This is
my friend, longtime colleague,
Music Library and extraordinary and
professional French horn player,
eva heater who will demonstrate here.
Come on over here. Right in the center.
Jeanne Kimble is in the basement
somewhere recording all of this. Oh yes.
Very excited to hear what a time
to be alive, Huh? Yeah. Um, so, uh,
Eva's going to just demonstrate
the physical process of
playing the French horn.
The Horn obviously is a brass instrument
and what makes the sound is a vibrating
column of air.
In this case,
the basic column or there is 12 and a
half feet long and there's something
called partials or the harmonic
series that happens in,
in anything with a screening or whatever.
But on the horn,
it's very distinct and that's what makes
the different most let me demonstrate
to the harmonic series.
Uh, uh, uh,
no I didn't use no hands.
That was just the notes that are naturally
on the 12 and a half foot of length
of vibrating air. That's, those are the,
that's the harmonic series that's on that.
And what the balance do is they shorten
and lengthen that librarian column of
air. Very much like a cello street
on think of board. You know,
the cellist is always shortening
and lengthening the uh,
the strings on doing the same thing.
I'm just doing it with a series of
switches instead of a finger one,
which we obviously don't have. Um, okay.
That's fine. That's great.
That's, that's the principal.
And when she says she overblowing what
that means is we'll keep emphasizing this
point today that uh,
and these partials that wins a sound
is made. You have not just one sound,
but that tube is dividing it up into
sections and all kinds of little sections
of that one. The tube are sounding
not just the biggest sound,
but the partials or the overtones,
the heart of the sea intervals
in the harmonic series. So,
uh, it's a whole series.
When we listened to a single tone,
it's a whole series.
And what ava was doing there is
playing out the notes in that series
successively. We'll keep
banging on that. Now,
if you would have a play
just the beginning of the
Zuora through stroke where
the trumpet part, can you
do that? Oh Man. What is it?
Well, whatever key you're in, what,
what a key are you in? What can,
would you like me to be in?
Well, could you, could we do see?
Oh,
okay.
Uh,
uh
hmm.
Okay.
That's nice that, that's
an, that's another note.
Thank you very much. Thank you. Okay.
Ava has another, yeah, another
gig out in Guilford said this morning.
So she's going to to run off and I'm
going to show you maybe if we can get our
slides up, is this overtone
series stuff. Okay. Okay.
It's a mathematical thing too,
which I hope I've got it on the slides.
Gentlemen, can you, I'm going
to hit what I was told to do.
Function F eight.
Is that right?
Yeah.
Ha. All right. Something came up and
then disappeared. All right, so come,
may I have a technical person
please bring press it one more time.
Uh,
eight.
Okay, so we don't have we done. All
right, so let's, I tell you what,
we're going to just leave this
up and I will bag the other slot.
I have slides with all
this information on it,
but we can't seem to bring these up. Uh,
what we've got here is the following,
this idea of partials and ava was
talking about with ratios two to one,
three to, to four to three, five
to four, six to five and so on.
And the point here is that the way
we differentiate between instruments,
anybody tell me this?
Why are you telling me this?
It's always better when students answer.
Why does a trumpet,
if I ask a trumpet to play this Pete p
a trumpet played it,
then I ask an oboe to play it.
The sound would be very different.
Why is that the case?
Gentlemen here,
different overtones,
well actually they all have
the same overtones in a way,
the same frequencies with sound,
but you've got it a 99% of it.
It's which partials are
particularly prominent,
have extra punch or extra
volume to it. Is it the, the,
the oboe may have the seventh partial,
very strong and the third partial,
very strong. Whereas the trumpet, I'm
just making all of this up. Of course,
the trumpet may have the second partial
on the fourth partial and the six
partial,
so it's,
which of these partials are sounding
within each of these instruments and the
physical properties of each of
these instruments are different.
It's the particular blend.
Here's a really dumb analogy.
Any Scotch drinkers in here? No, of course
not. You're way too young to do that,
but think about a blended scotch. You
know, you'll get a little of this little,
this little of this and it makes up about
whatever it is that you end up with a
particular recipe for that liquid.
Well,
we have a particular recipe
for instrumental Tambre
or instrumental color and
it's the intensity of the overtones
with or partials within each particular
instrument that creates that.
Okay.
Now we're going to go on and talk about
a woodwind instrument here. So Linda,
come on up. Linda is is a best
soonest. Uh, she's also a,
this is Linda Paul who will be our,
one of our principal tas here.
She is a phd candidate in
the Department of music.
Just passed your qualifying
exam with flying colors.
So here she is to demonstrate
the bassoon for us.
Lowest member of the woodwind family.
All right,
so you have,
you read in the book that the
decision is a double reed instrument.
And so just to show you what that
looks like, you've probably seen it,
but if you haven't, two pieces
of wood vibrate together.
When I blow through them,
always a
check it up before I play in her notes.
And as you will probably suspect
by the link to the bassoon,
it can play very loaded.
And if I put a little rag in the top,
I can get it even a little bit lower
than that. You didn't bring one,
but actually amazingly, it's
a very versatile and can
also play very high notes.
As you can see,
there are a lot of keys on it.
There are nine keys for
my left thumb alone,
so I'm kind of switching between these
on the back here and many others.
And because of that I can do very
high and I'll just demonstrate that.
Okay,
so that's just to give you a sense
of the range because of this sort of
particular character of the city sound,
it's often used to play sort of funny
little low note characters in the
orchestra.
For example,
if you're familiar with Peter and the
wolf and be different instruments play
different characters.
The bassoon is the grandfather?
Nope.
Cool.
Okay, great. Thanks
that. That's really fun.
Now Jacob Adams is going,
is a professional a violist here in new
haven? What's the name of your core tet?
Jacob does VINCA string quartet,
so keep an eye out for them.
They're based here in new haven. She'll
come on out, Jacob and um, uh, let,
oh he is a violist,
not a violinist,
but the principle here
is pretty much the same.
So tell us about the
construction of the instrument.
Okay.
So obviously we've now seen a little
bit of the brass family and the woodwind
family and the other principal.
A section of the orchestra would,
Bob is to be the string family. Um, the
viola is very similar to the violence,
so anything I say about the viola
applies to the violin as well.
And of course you all are probably
familiar with violence and the size of the
violas are a little bit bigger. This
particular one's about 16 inches long, um,
building so I can show it better,
uh,
violins or maybe go up about 12 inches.
They have a slightly smaller body to them.
Um,
but violence of els have the same
general construction. Um, we,
we, uh, all the sounds are
produced by the strings, uh,
on the instrument and how the bone
is pulled across the instruments.
The Bose made out of typically horse
hair from tales of courses. Um,
the strings are now metallic,
but 16th,
18th century, they would have
been made out of cat gut. Um,
that was much more common
and still some people,
okay. So I'm sorry we were, I got lots
of things going on here. There's money,
so just play, um, uh, scale, uh, quickly.
And then the Vibrato Pitsa
Kado and Tremolo for it.
So again, this is on a viola, so does
a deeper darker tamber than a violin.
But here's the scale.
Oh, you did something
there at the end. Do,
do you have too much coffee this morning
and started shaking with it? Yeah.
So tell us about what you
were doing there at the end.
So there are all sorts of different little
technique things you can do to create
different colors and sounds on,
on all string instruments.
So this applies to any of them.
Uh,
one of them is the technique you
something to do with my left hand where I
wiggled it a little bit. It's called the
Bravo. You hear the human voices as well.
You can do it on other instruments but,
and then a string instrument.
It's the difference.
I'll play a melody without Sobrato
and with the grotto so you can see the
difference.
Uh,
uh,
so that's what the ads are Prato
not that interesting in my opinion.
So with the Bronto,
mm.
And you can vary the width and the speed
and the length, there's a lot of fair.
Okay.
Then just quickly play a pitch for sure.
Okay. And then finally, Tremolo.
Yes.
A little excitement or a little filler
to the music sometimes. All right. Great.
Thank you,
Jacob.
Very much
so. I Dunno if I get, whether
technically this will work or not.
I've tried all morning to get this
to work. I have it up on my screen,
but I don't see it up on the screen there.
Can I have a tech assistant to do?
All right. We'll go back
here to try this. It began,
nothing happened.
Yeah.
Well that's why I asked
somebody to stand up here. Yeah.
It doesn't do me much good
to have somebody in the
back going like this. Okay.
What I would like, one I wanted
to show you was a clip. Uh,
that actually one my daughter brought to
my attention. Um, just this past weekend,
she was watching television. America
has talent. Anybody watched this?
Americans talent? And she
said, Dad, you've got to watch.
This is the most amazing thing.
They've got these two guys on here
called nothing but strings. So I did,
I went to, she did, she
sent me the link to Youtube.
I'll let see if we can get this to go.
I don't know.
Send me fine
to do something.
I love with the person that,
uh,
so obviously the violin is not just this
stodgy old thing from the renaissance.
It has some legs today, uh,
used in folk music used in,
sometimes you see it in, in
Nashville, playing with country music,
that kind of thing. Uh, is this a travesty
to use a violin with, with hip hop here?
I guess this is hip hop. Of
course not. This is wonderful.
This is the best thing that has happened
to the violin in the last hundred years.
There will be millions of
kids out there now to, Gee,
I'd like to learn to play the violin too.
So this is wonderful.
This sort of cross, uh,
semination of, of genres here,
bringing this particular instrument,
the traditional classical violin
into the popular realm. All right,
so let's put that aside. We've talked a
little bit about sound production here.
I've got two pieces I'm
going to work with here. Uh,
for the end of our session,
we have 15 minutes left and
here are these two pieces.
The first you can see on the board up
there is by another Russian composer Modez
resort ski.
It's called Polish ox card from
his work pictures at an exhibition.
What happened was he had a friend, the
friend died, the friend was an artist.
A friend left these pictures
as an homage to the painter.
Mazurski sat down and
tried to come up with,
create a musical response to each of
these paintings that were on display.
Now this is a piece that's always
interested me because the painting is very
pedestrian.
It's of an old Polish ox cart sitting
on some godforsaken road in rural Russia
somewhere.
So how do you make that work as music?
How do you turn that
visual image in to music?
How do you turn that into a
sort of live sonic escape?
And I should say at the outset,
I'm going to prejudice,
you're listening here just a little bit.
I hear this as me being in the
center and this oxcart starting.
Could you start either side? It doesn't
matter. Everybody moves left to right.
So I'm going to hear this moving left
to right. It comes in front of me,
almost raw rolls over top of me,
runs me and then disappears to my right.
So as we listen to this,
you think about what are the techniques
by which resort ski creates this musical
action scene. You should be able to come
up with two pretty good ideas here too.
Pretty good answers.
All right, here we go.
Nice and loud.
The instrument is playing.
That is playing
is a low tuba, Tuba, low brass instrument.
It doesn't sound much like a Tuba cause
it's actually playing in the higher
register of the instrument,
but it is a tube.
Now, this strange, turn it
up just a little bit. Streams
come in with a counter ID,
complimentary ideas.
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
okay.
Give me one pretty straight forward way.
This happened.
What did he do there?
Yes. A young lady out here please. Okay.
Crescendo from beginning to end.
Yeah,
so like a giant wedge.
So that's why the cart
seems to be in front of you.
And so we're talking about musical
volume here. It started very quietly.
It built up to this huge center in which
we had the bass drum pounding away.
They're in a snare drum coming in to
give the effect of the entire earth is
rattling at that particular
particular point.
And then as it passed by you,
the thunder pass by you and off you
went into the distance quietly into the
distance and it was, we'll
come back to that. But uh, uh,
how did that happen?
We'll listen to the end of that.
And just one moment is kind
of a disintegration of the
sound at the end of this
disintegration of the sound at the end.
So let's pick it up.
So that's one big, one big
way. This happened. One,
that's probably the big ticket item here.
There's another way, a more subtle way.
Any thoughts about that?
Yes,
yes. The instrumentation that,
can you elaborate on that?
Great.
Right. So there's a kind of wedge shape
with regard to the instruments too.
He starts with the lowest instruments,
the lowest instruments, uh,
and then uh,
goes to the high instruments and then
back to low instruments at the end.
Let's just review, well, no, we won't
review this. Let's not review that.
Okay.
We don't have time to review that,
but let's go on to say the following that
what moves Mussorgsky knew there was a
very basic principle of acoustics
and what is that principle?
Yeah, I beg your pardon.
Well, to some extent,
I'm going to give an
example example of that,
of the train kind of going by you and
the sound hitting off in the other,
other direction to yes, to some
extent it is that, yes. Um, uh,
but what I was thinking about here is
this idea that the lowest sounds create or
the longest sound waves
and they last the longest,
lowest sounds create the largest
sound waves and they last the longest.
The lowest sounds lasts the longest.
Why might this be the case? Are here,
uh, uh, not having too much
confidence in our slides this morning.
I went ahead and put this one up on
the board here. Here is one pitch.
Here is a picture of a string, an octave
higher, so you can see it this way.
As you probably know,
if you take a long string and pluck it,
it's going to take that long string along
time to pass that sort of cycle if you
will. Just one pass through that
cycle, the string, half the length.
We'll pass through that cycle two times
so that you can kind of graph these up
here as one long,
low sound or one faster
vibrating sound an octave higher.
So again,
low sounds or low
frequencies travel farther.
Now you've experienced
this in your own life.
You're standing on a street corner
here in new haven in the distance.
What do you hear an automobile approaching
with a souped up audio system in it
and what sound do you hear
at the very first room room,
room room, that kind of thing. There
may be too junior to Du, Du, Du, Du, Du,
Du, Du, Du, Du, Du.
And then maybe some kind of melody will
come in and then it'll all come together
right in front of you and it kind
of disappear in the distance.
You're at a football game,
you've probably experienced this too.
The band is marching on the field.
Suddenly they do the doppler effect where
they turn their backs to you in a way
and they're playing away from you
and you hear very little sound.
What instrumental sound do you hear?
Boom,
boom, boom. The bass drum and the Tuba,
or in the marching band
would be a sousaphone.
They would call it the bass drum and Tuba.
So Mazurski knew this kind of thing and
because he's a professional musician and
was playing off of it to create this
rather unusual and remarkable, uh,
musical soundscape here. Okay,
I have five minutes left.
I'd like to do one last piece.
It's another piece by Ricard Strauss.
It kind of brings us to
the end of Ricard Strauss,
our discussion of Ricard's Josh, we'll
say goodbye to him here in our course,
it's called death and transfiguration,
death and transfiguration.
And I hear this as a companion piece.
It kind of pendant to
the Zuora through stroke.
One sort of opens up the beginning of
life here and the other closes it down,
uh,
through a referencing of death.
There's a interesting anecdote about
Strauss and that is that on his deathbed,
he said to his daughter,
Alice, he said, Alice,
it's the funniest thing.
Dying is exactly as I composed
it in death and transfiguration.
What an odd thing to say,
but in any event,
here's how this works.
We've been talking about this overtone
series with Zahra through Straw,
Ava Palade overtone series. He's basically
working up to the upper partials.
Now.
He's going to work down the partials.
You're going to close it back down here
with death and he's going to close it
back down using a process that
we frequently encounter in music,
and that is this idea of dissonance
resolving two consonants.
Here's a dissonance.
Here's a consonant.
They're precise technical reasons
why these are the way they are,
but let me try to, to cut to the
chase here with dissonant intervals,
they tend to be frequencies that are
sounding right next to each other,
very close by frequencies.
They sound dissonant.
If you allow a little bit of spacing,
a little more space between
your frequencies, they're
a little bit farther apart,
then you can move from closeness to
spacing and you get the consonants.
Generally speaking,
dissonant intervals have ratios such as
nine to eight for the whole step or 17
to 16 for the half step.
They're irrational numbers
and these irrational numbers
like to move to rational
numbers.
They like to move to consonants as they
like to move to intervals that are based
on things such as two to one and
three to two or maybe four to three.
So that's the,
the the principle of this idea of
dissonance resolving two consonants.
So we're going to listen
now to the end of Strauss's.
Death and transfiguration did the death
year and again we've got the idea of the
octave,
then the fifth and the fourth week
working up farther and farther in these
partials and we've got some of these
notes right next to each other and they
want to move to the stable notes.
So we're going to be hearing a lot of
a note right above the tonic wanting to
pull down to that tonic note.
We're going to hear a lot of
unknowns right above the dominant,
wanting to pull down to the dominant.
So let's listen to this.
We have about three minutes, I think. Um,
we'll hear it and I'll comment a bit as we
go.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
yeah, just working with the
four note and motive here.
Whoa, strange little dissonant chord.
They're resolving the consonants
here.
It's
just the basic primordial note upon
which all these other tones are built.
Okay. So that's Ricard
Strauss as approach to death,
not particularly relevant
to you young people,
but for older gentlemen such
as Professor Kagan and myself,
we're getting close to
that right. Dot. So, uh,
thank you all for staying with us this
morning and hope you will enjoy that
music. We'll see you in section starting
this Thursday. If you have any questions,
come up and see me or send me an email.